well extraordinary stuff and it's made
headlines of course around the entire
world I've never had so many calls and
texts and messages and emails asking for
interviews or just commenting
um well then this morning in his first
public appearance since the interview
Cristiano said he won't be silenced
in my life the best timing is always my
timing obviously on your side it's easy
to give an opinion it's easy to write
many times the truth many lies about me
the best timing is always my timing well
we can all have our view about how
Cristiano Ronaldo might be feeling why
he did this but sometimes the best
people to ask are those who've been in
The Cauldron of high level sport Kevin
Peterson is for me the best of the
generation was International career for
England was cut short after high profile
Fallout with his employees the ECB and
he joins Me Now Kevin great to see you
when you when you watched it what did
you make of Ronaldo's mindset why he did
this what may have been behind it
I think he's at the end of his tether
um I think if you read the reports and
you you see why he's been in the news
and how many times he's been in the news
for all the wrong reasons by him but all
the right reasons by clearly his
employees and these things happen
to people for reasons that they don't
want
and it's when I was watching I mean I
just got back from Dubai yesterday and I
got up every morning and I just watched
it I was one of your 15 million then
watched the full interview I I didn't
watch you I watched him peers and it was
it was it was incredibly
it was incredibly enlightening because
you can sort of see a similar position
to what I had now not for any stretch of
the imagination am I sitting here saying
that I'm as famous as Cristiano Ronaldo
because it's absolutely not true you've
just talked about how famous he is
but what you could see is that actually
he's very unhappy in a place that he
should be happy and feels disrespected
well forget disrespect I hate the word
disrespect there are two places when you
are in The Cauldron and you are top lead
at the top athlete and you're right at
the top of your game where you should
feel happy you should feel comfortable
and you should be able to do whatever
you want because that's where you should
be free that's at home with your family
and the second place is at the training
ground you can see he's unhappy at the
training ground now I know that
Carrington and I think it's called
Carrington where man united trains their
facility isn't up to scratch no have a
look at his social media and look where
he trains look how he practices to be
the best you have to
live the best life and to be the best
you have to continually need to grow and
we all talk about being that high level
athlete it's that extra one percent what
is it like I remember this review when
you were going through your problems
with England we spoke a lot over that
time and the thing that really incends
to you is all this drip drip drip of
stuff that was coming out about you most
of which I knew wasn't true because you
were telling me the reality Cristiano
the same thing it's the constant drip
drip drip of negative stories about him
95 of which he says are completely
untrue I've been talking to him
regularly for six months yeah through
this process and I I know when I fact
check these things in real time he said
it's not true it's not true it's not
true or one is true or whatever
you're overriding negative well you know
you've been editor of newspapers you've
been in the media there are stories that
get drip fed to journalists yes about
certain people who want to know them who
want to knife certain athletes and one
thing I hate is that tall puppy syndrome
I mean why can't he be celebrated here I
mean I was in Dubai and I got back
yesterday and no one can bill believe
how this country are going after
Cristiano Ronaldo they cannot believe it
the people in the airports in in the
hotels everybody why on Earth are people
going at him I mean he is such a proven
performer but you can see his
frustration and you can and you can
identify the issues he goes back to a
facility that's not up to scratch he
goes to a facility where he wants to be
the best where he wants to maintain
standards you say you don't like the
word disrespect I mean he used that a
lot because he feels that if you're not
respected for what you've achieved in
the game and he still believes he has
lots of obvious super fit as you know
you were very fit actually when you left
the England so you could have played for
another five six years he thinks he's
got another two or three years at least
he felt there was a just a disrespect
from everyone there that had decision
making power yeah well I I think that he
is at that level where he commands
respect because of what he's achieved in
the game I do I agree with you I think
he's the greatest footballer that's
played the game he's he he he he turns
the needle that's what he does and
there's a reason and why he's still
making headlines four or five days after
the interview because of who he is
there's not many athletes in the world
that can do that all right and so
there's a reason also why he's in that
position
because of the way that he practices
because of the way that he lives his
life because of the sacrifices that he's
had to make as an individual to achieve
what he's achieved you understand that I
know that you you know for all your
obvious many faults uh not as many as
you but for all your money faults uh
everyone we've got one big fault we've
chosen you but even if your colleagues
you know had a problem with you
personally whatever they all said the
same thing you were the first in and
last out of training Ronaldo the same
you never hear anything about his
training regime he's unbelievably
self-driven and you had that as well
whilst having this polarizing reputation
about you do you relate to him on that
level I I think it's it's those one
percenters and and to be the best you
you have to tick every single box and I
and I'll go back to it you have to be
happy at home where he is
um but where he also hasn't been over
the last six months I mean you're only
the two things came together because he
lost he lost his best you're only as
you're as a parent you're only as happy
as you unhappiest child right and I he
went through total exactly right exactly
right and and you know what if what he
said is true about them not believing
what's been happening with this family
and I can't say whether it's true or not
he says it is true
that's almost unforgivable yeah because
he's a human at the end of the day yes
he's super famous yes he's worth
hundreds of millions of dollars he's
achieved that because he's amazing at
what he does he plays what did you think
of the particular point he made on the
field when ten Hogg the new coach
doesn't bring him on against Manchester
City and says he did side of respect and
then the next game their winning easily
against Tottenham and he wants to bring
him on with three minutes to go
completely contradicting what he'd said
the week before
I think and and my foot more knowledge
isn't amazing but I think there was a
quote from ten Hogg talking about the
fact that he was the fourth in line to
Captain United a couple of days or a
couple of games after
um his issue where he walked off the
field it's something that even if you
think it as a coach you don't say it in
public and that's what I can't
understand now that's why I actually
agree with everything that Cristiano has
said purely based on the fact that no
coach if he cares about his player would
do that I agree Mourinho why was
Mourinho amazing why did Lampard Terry
drug but all these guys I mean I did all
my rehab for my achilles at uh um uh
Cobham Chelsea's training ground why do
they love Mourinho if the team had a bad
game Mourinho made the game about it
thank you was the same all the great
managers I think protect their players
you've got to protect your players